I once knew a girl who could dance to
the world a heart of a kid her glory now
hid beauty is her name she is on her way
to fame but I'm telling you all she has
not remained the same secrecy brings
pleasure she seems to be getting better
but while I write this letter my eyes
get wetter beauty now lost her stakes
have a high cost and she's tossed in
Boston a life of exhaust her pain I can
relate she's insane with an out of mine
state for her I worry for her I'm sorry
her emotions are buried her heart has
been bullied her abuse has been tallied
her life is storied popularity and
hilarity is her game cutely and freely
hides all the shame what's your secret
what's your cost the abuser is her
favorite now she's more than just lost
when are you going to awake when are you
going to stop being fake why do you lie
especially to yourself talk about deny
an unusual conduct for oneself a liar
and a cheater that made an enabler a
manipulator and abuser that made you go
darker you're lost in a world that is
not your own the cost of consequence
will keep you alone you are eternal
beauty but do you see yourself that way
your vision is dark and cloudy so please
tell me why do you stay let's open up
the past because your perception is very
much miscast but you're backed into a
corner surrounded by family and friends
yet your energy is still that of a loner
you've been misused you've been abused
and that bastard accused let's open up
that brain and anxious heart well it
looks confused is it addiction or is
just justification look at the present
through your soul and you'll see a
reflection your internal pain causes
much guilt and shame why you maintain a
thing that will drain perception of
light is everyone's sight but listen to
my invite because your spirit remains in
the night I am your ally and I to deny
but I'm always nearby if you ever need
to cry it was a lover's pursuit that I
guess was cute wats four years later and
now a friendship uproots I don't have
the answers all I have is some prayers
but when I look into your eyes I do
understand that a friendship for us is
part of our homeland